pour certains c'est anodin mais pour eux
c'est clémentine carottes et pommes de
terre sont une manne providentielle
malgré toutes les galères de la crise
sanitaire les étudiants de l'association
la baffe ont pu se réorganiser et
proposer de nouveau leurs paniers de
fruits et légumes
on est là depuis 7h du matin j'ai su
père fouras je sens plus mes pieds et
qu'est ce qui vous pousse à participer à
cette opération sur cette distribution
là on fait à peu près 400 panier donc
c'est énorme on touche 400 étudiants ça
vaut le coup d'avoir froid du coup ça
veut clouer depuis bientôt sept ans et
ce grossiste des environs de besançon
qui accompagne les étudiants de la baf
un professionnel qui n'hésite pas à
donner des conseils pour faire un panier
de fruits et légumes au meilleur rapport
qualité prix
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut
absolument leur montrer aussi que nous
en tant que professionnel on est à leurs
côtés
je pense que ça c'est important ben pour
qu'ils sentent qu'il ya vraiment des
gens qui pensent aussi à eux c'est la
première fois que les étudiants du
centre ville viennent retirer leur
panier dans ce restaurant
d'habitude ils déboursent 5 euros la
grâce à plusieurs partenaires c'est
devenu gratuit
c'est un peu dur en ce moment je
travaille plus et compliqué
c'est
je travaille dans un restaurant j'étais
serveuse ans puisque le soir et le
week-end dans la vie d'avant le coc vide
le patron de ce restaurant avec son bar
de nuit employés en majorité des
étudiants
tout s'est arrêté pour lui aussi fait
quinze ans que les étudiants nous font
vivre aujourd'hui c'est peut-être un
autre tour pas de les faire vivre mais
si on peut leur donner un petit coup de
main qui n'est pas grand chose
finalement puisque l'établissement est
fermé on ajuste électricité à fournir et
puis ouvrir les portes
les bénévoles de la baf profite aussi de
ces rencontres pour prendre le pouls
auprès des étudiants et transmettre si
besoin les informations au pouce pour
d'autres soutiens savoir qu'on n'est pas
tout seul et qu'on a un peu tous dans le
même bateau avec la vidéoconférence tout
ça c'est vrai que c'est un peu ça fait
plaisir de retrouver des étudiants qui
sont dans le même cas que nous mais qui
arrive quand même à s'en sortir aussi
donc c'est ça qu'est bien que se serrer
les coudes en temps de crise c'est
devenu pour eux une évidence